MALE SPEAKER 1: Hmm, this
all looks so delectable.
How does anyone choose?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Carefully, sir.
There's some exquisite new
choices in the 23.2 menu.
I definitely recommend the
DayNight theme from AppCompat.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Interesting.
Do you have anything that's
fresh, like fresh, fresh?
MALE SPEAKER 2: I think we
might have something for you.
If you're looking for
totally new features
or important
improvements, version 23.2
of the Android Support
Library doesn't disappoint.
There's two new additions to
the Support Library family--
support-vector-drawable
and support animated vector
drawable.
These bring the power and
flexibility of vector drawables
to all API 7 and higher
devices, and animated vector
drawables to all API
11 and higher devices.
I expect smaller APKs
from you as you all
replace multiple PNG assets
with a single vector drawable.
AppCompat is already taking
advantage of vector drawables
in this release to save
everyone some space.
And it provides a handy
source Compat attribute
for image views
and image buttons,
making it easy to use
your new vector drawables.
Check out our blog post for all
the details on how this works.
Now, that's not all that
changed with AppCompat, though.
In addition to the
current Theme.AppCompat
and Theme.AppCompat.Light,
there's
a new Theme.AppCompat.DayNight
theme specifically
for API 14 and higher devices.
Now making a UI that
adapts to the time of day
just means picking the right
theme and testing thoroughly.
You'll be able to manually
change between day and night
at the app level
or activity level
with new methods in AppCompat
Delegate, perfect for testing
or even as a setting you
expose to your users.
Another new feature in
23.2 is the addition
to the Android Design Support
Library-- bottom sheets.
[FANFARE]
Now, this coordinator layer
behavior attaches to any view,
allows you to drag it
open and closed, peak
or hide completely.
There's even a BottomSheetDialog
and BottomSheetDialogFragment
for easily styling a
dialogue as a bottom sheet.
Magical.
[HARPS PLAY]
Now, if you have a
media-playing app,
you'll be happy to know
that this release also
includes
MediaBrowserServiceCompat
and MediaBrowserCompat,
allowing you
to use previously only
Lollipop and higher APIs all
the way back to API 4.
Whether you're looking
for an easy way
to connect your media
playback service to your UI,
or looking to integrate with
Android Auto and Android Wear,
this is the API to look into.
Of course, there's another
Android out there-- Android TV.
The Leanback Support
Library's GuidedStepFragment,
which lets you guide users
through a series of steps,
has received a number
of enhancements.
The blog has all the details
if that's your thing,
as well as information on
all the other new features
in version 23.2.
So have you made your selection?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Uh,
yeah, I think I have.
I'm going to go for all of it.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 2: There's
actually only one person
who's made it through
that ordeal successfully.
[MUSIC PLAYING]